instance this thing on the top left here
is techtio router these guys from mit
they made a handheld router that's a
little robotic computer controlled
router right so it's a little handheld
router like you'd use in woodworking but
it um the router itself can move a
couple inches back and forth within the
little case that you hold right it's got
a little camera on it it's got a little
screen and what it does is you can
actually say i want to cut a straight
line from here to here and you're as
long as you keep the dot in the circle
it will adjust the router to take all
your like you know jaggy motions out and
just cut a perfectly straight line
right or i want to cut a star shape out
and i don't have the skill to actually
do that by hand but the machine will
totally help you do the fine motor
control to make that work right so i
think we're going to see a lot more
stuff like that where it's not about
making some machine like we have like we
have a giant robot that does the exact
same thing and i don't have to keep a
dot in a circle or anything i program it
tell what to do walk away it cut stuff
while i'm off working um you know but in
this instance anybody can pick that up
and use it right you don't have to
program it you don't have to know cad
you like that kind of semi-automated
kind of approach is is just huge
a great thing on the top right there too
is
people working alongside robots so a
robot arm like this one that's carving
out foam it will kill you if you stand
next to it right if it swings over while
you're working next to it it will it
will cause a lot of damage to you
they're big they're heavy they're very
powerful so this thing has to be in a
cage by osha rules and you can't go
anywhere near it when it's working right
but that robot up there at the top
that's a special robot that this new
this company called universal robotics
is making it's all belt driven
internally if that robot arm hits you it
doesn't hurt you at all it just hits you
and and that's it like it has a slip
belt system on the inside so if it hits
something it doesn't do any damage it
just stops right so that arm is what's
loading and unloading that cnc mill that
that machinist is working at so instead
of the machinist wasting his time
loading and unloading the mill the robot
arm loads and unloads the mill and that
guy can do higher value tasks right so
semi-automated like i'm not trying to
make it to where
nobody's ever needed but i'm keeping a
human in the loop because humans are
awesome and they do great jobs right
but at the same time i'm working side by
side with them
the other thing is that a friend of ours
that does big massive sculptures he did
the bow and arrow on the waterfront here
in san francisco his name is bill
chrysler he's a really awesome guy and
um
he has a cnc machine the size of a
basketball court
it wouldn't fit in this room it's a five
axis machine he bought it from a boat
builder it's massive massive thing
for a lot of their projects when they're
doing complicated sculptural work
they'll actually have the cnc router
only get it about 80 of the way there
and then their talented crew of
sculptors comes in and finishes the 20
by hand
because it's faster right it's that 80
20 rule it's like the machine can do 80
of the work in 20 of the time and then
that last little bit of finishing work
is done by hand because that's where the
artistry and the craft really come into
it to make the piece really good like if
you tried to make it to where it came
off the cnc machine 100 done you're
going to spend 100 times the amount of
time in programming the cnc machine and
it still might not look as good because
it didn't have that final touch that a
talented sculptor is able to do
and um
lastly uh
you know
this is a protein folding diagram one of
the cool things is when you start to
make things with robots is you can make
things the joke that we say is that you
can make things that want to be built
right so if you put all the parts in a
box and you shook the box long enough
you'd wind up with the assembled cabinet
like what's under the stairs over here
right it's a theoretical idea but
basically we can make it so that stuff
only goes together the right way right
so again it's semi-automated i'm not
trying to make a machine that will
assemble cabinets for me instead of
making really smart parts that are
really simple for anybody to put
together to make a cabinet so
everything's kind of like ikea-like or
something you know
and nature is a great example of that
[Music]
you